football et de flux a produit le produit
seul joueur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cinq ans jean marc bosman jouer ici
numéro 10 au royal club de liège en
première division du championnat de
belgique
une belle carrière lui semble promise
hélas pour lui
aux termes d'un contrat de deux ans son
club lui propose un salaire divisé par
quatre donc soit jacques senez contrat
là et je rechignais pour nous et pour
des road carottes
soit je m'y opposais donc stop je ne
signait pas je ne pouvais plus jouer je
restais la propriété du club jean marc
décide alors de partir pour dunkerque
c'est là que commence son cauchemar
liège exige du club français une somme
exorbitante
[Musique]
parce que deux clubs n'arrivaient pas à
se mettre d'accord pour des histoires de
gros sous
moi je ne pouvais pas rester mais je ne
pouvais pas partir dans j'étais bloqué
il se fait que mon transfert échoué
désormais le monde du football devra se
conformer aux règles du monde du travail
les indemnités de transfert en fin de
contrat sont jugées illégales
c'est david qui a battu au lieu de quoi
c'est le petit qui a écrasé le grand
quoi mais voilà je souriais parce que
dans ma tête je ne vivais à voilà que
soit la fifa ou l'uefa ils ont mis les
choux par terre ils seront à mes fils
[Applaudissements]
0,3 des jouets pour cent des joueurs
gagnent leur vie comme des comme des
cochons ont pu dire c'est astronomique
aujourd hui sans mal sa carrière
professionnelle été remis plus de
travail je n'avais plus dans le monde du
football c'était hors de question j'ai
été complètement banni
[Musique]
une période très dure ou n'accepte pas
ce cette non reconnaissance alors que
finalement le réflexe j'ai fait du bien
quoi
[Musique]
tu leur mets à jour pouvoir me dire oh
je termine le mois apaisé sans pouvoir
me tracasser avec toutes ses factures
[Musique]
vous savez il ya des joueurs maintenant
pense qu'au profit qui sont en fait une
sorte même pas qui je suis d'ailleurs
[Musique]